Deadpool 2 was filled with twists and surprises,
like the unexpected demise of the entire X-Force
team.
But maybe the biggest shock of all was the
reveal of the biggest bad guy of them all
- the Juggernaut.
So how did Ryan Reynolds and company manage
to keep Juggernaut a surprise for so long?
And how exactly did they make Juggernaut at
all?
Here's a look at some surprising secrets the
biggest fans may not know about Juggernaut
in Deadpool 2.
Top secret project
Deadpool 2 kept a lot of its biggest jokes
a secret, like the unexpected cameos of superstars
Brad Pitt and Matt Damon.
And keeping spoilers off the internet was
no easy task, as writer and executive producer
Paul Wernick revealed in the special features
on Deadpool 2's home release.
"Sometimes the secrecy thing gets ridiculous.
You know, our sides came in red because apparently you can't photocopy red."
And then she shreds them. It's like working in the CIA sometimes."
But the biggest source of leaks turned out
incredibly random, as Juggernaut's surprise
appearance was almost spoiled by another surprise
appearance, when legendary Guns n' Roses guitarist
Slash turned up on set.
Reynolds said it was a security nightmare.
"Suddenly all of these pictures of Slash were on people's phone, with like, Juggernaut in the background."
"I'm like, 'Guys, you can't post any of those! At least Photoshop the crap out of them!'"
The blob
Even though Juggernaut was created using CGI,
the actors on the set still needed a reference
to play off of during filming.
The solution?
A giant padded dummy.
It helped the actors nail their performances,
but it also led to even more problems keeping
the Juggernaut's appearance secret, as writer
Rhett Reese explained.
"If you've seen the physical reference, it is DEFINITELY Juggernaut.
It's like his outline, you can see his helmet and then below him is this amorphous blob."
The big problem?
That signature helmet, which couldn't belong
to anyone else.
"Anyone who has any background in comics, if they were on set that day, would spy that particular getup and go
"Hah! Juggernaut's going to be in the movie."
The man in the iron mask
Since an amorphous blob wouldn't have been
particularly scary for audiences - no offense
to fans of The Blob - the folks behind Deadpool
decided to use CGI to animate Juggernaut.
And when we say it was the folks behind Deadpool,
we mean that the role was actually played
by the team of director David Leitch
and Ryan Reynolds himself.
Yep, it's true: Reynolds provided the voice
and did the motion capture for the body, while
Leitch did the motion capture for the Juggernaut's
facial expressions.
And the reason was simple: it was just more
efficient to do it themselves rather than
waste time bringing another actor up to speed
on the role.
"He's definitely a mashup of us and that's really born out of the need to work efficiently."
"It's sort of a weird amalgamation."
"This incredible team of renderers are the guys that bring him to life. That one took a village,  that was all of us jumping in and making the Juggernaut."
Black Bob
Juggernaut's appearance in the movie was also
nearly revealed thanks to the casting of a
completely different character — Jack Kesy as Black Tom Cassidy.
In the comics, of course, Black Tom and Juggernaut
are partners.
So in order to keep the secret, Fox decided
to use a different code name when making the
casting announcement.
Unfortunately, according to Wernick, that
didn't quite work.
"It was released that Jack was playing, I think it was Black Bob."
"Which was a terrible idea. Ya know, they couldn't have come up with anything other than Black Blank? Couldn't it have been like, 'Larry'"?
As it turned out, Black Tom barely even appeared
in Deadpool 2, meaning this secret ultimately
almost leaked on his behalf for no real reason.
Whoops!
The irresistible force
During the film's climax, Juggernaut was seemingly
stopped for good when the good guys stuck
an electrical cord into… the wrong socket.
Well, before you get too weepy for poor ol
Jugs, though, take heart, as eagle-eyed fans
noticed that in the film's final scene, Juggernaut
appears to be alive after all.
So what does this mean for Juggernaut's future?
Nobody knows for sure, but chances are, we
haven't seen the last of him.
After all, it's pretty hard to stop a Juggernaut.